hey hola a todos hay algo que tenemos
que checar antes de que podamos ver la
forma vectorial de la aproximación
cuadrática de funciones de varias
variables digamos que tenemos una
expresión de este estilo una constante
que multiplica a x cuadrada y luego
sumamos otra constante b que multiplica
a x por ye y finalmente tenemos otra
constante que multiplica a de cuadrada
muy bien y aquí en este caso a veces son
constantes mientras que x y son
variables verdad y para este tipo de
expresiones tenemos un nombre muy
rimbombante y se les conoce como formas
cuadráticas entonces esta expresión que
tenemos acá arriba es una forma
cuadrática y en realidad lo que esto
significa es que tenemos todos estos
términos que tenemos son cuadráticas es
decir es x cuadrada x por jay y cuadrada
son multiplicaciones de dos variables
verdad x con xx
por supuesto que para las formas
cuadráticas no podemos tener términos
digamos line
es como x tampoco podemos tener términos
constantes como 2 y tampoco podemos
sumarlos simplemente son términos
cuadráticas muy bien entonces nosotros
pues ya saben cómo son los matemáticos
verdad en realidad les gusta ponerles
nombres muy rimbombantes a todo y que
solo hacen que se vean más extraños de
lo que ya son verdad entonces la
pregunta que tenemos es cómo podríamos
expresar esta forma cuadrática pero de
forma vectorial entonces quizás la
primera analogía que nosotros tenemos es
el caso de las expresiones lineales en
donde tenemos una constante por x más
otra constante porque porque más
una última constante digamos por zeta
verdad entonces tenemos x jay-z con
variables perdón mientras que abc son
constantes entonces una forma que
tenemos para expresar esto que tenemos
aquí de forma vectorial es utilizando el
producto punto ponemos ponemos en un
vector
e hice bien este es un vector en donde
colocamos nuestras tres constantes y
luego hacemos el producto punto con el
vector x que se está muy bien donde
estoy donde éste es nuestro vector con
variables entonces justamente digamos
podríamos poner esto como en una en un
vector b que lo estamos haciendo digamos
en negritas verdad y hacemos el producto
punto con un vector x cuyas coordenadas
en efectos serían x 67 y por eso lo
ponemos como en negrita es verdad y
entonces esta expresión esencialmente se
ve solo como es como si fuera una
constante por la variable sólo que en
este caso la constante es en realidad un
vector constante y la variable es un
vector variable verdad y el producto
pues no es el producto usual sino que
usamos el producto punto ok entonces
esencialmente esto se ve como una
constante por variable pero ahora
nosotros lo que ganamos con esta
expresión es que podemos tener 100
- en nuestro vector constante y 100
variables en x verdad en el vector x
entonces la pregunta sería podemos hacer
algo similar con las formas cuadráticas
y esto es importante porque si queremos
digamos añadir otra variable a la forma
cuadrática entonces por ejemplo
podríamos tener más otra constante por
el producto de x con zeta podríamos
agregar otra constante con el producto
de zeta con zeta que sería zeta cuadrada
más otra constante con el producto de g
por zeta verdad entonces si nos damos
cuenta al agregar variables las formas
cuadráticas se vuelven cada vez más
complicadas verdad entonces para poder
resolver esta pregunta que hemos
planteado vamos a modificar ligeramente
la forma cuadrática y vamos a poner un 2
aquí y en realidad no pasa nada si
ponemos el 2 en realidad estaríamos
considerando como como una constante
distinta una una especie de ve distinta
pero esencialmente sigue siendo una
constante entonces ya verás más adelante
porque necesitamos
ok entonces te voy a decir cómo es que
lo podemos hacer vamos a considerar una
matriz una matriz de 2 por 2 en este
caso donde tengamos la entrada a y la
entrada se en la diagonal y digamos aquí
vamos a tener b y vamos a procurar que
sea simétrica digamos con respecto a
esta diagonal entonces para que sea
simétrica vamos a considerar b de este
lado muy bien entonces déjenme quitar
esas líneas vamos a considerar b de este
de este lado muy bien donde a veces son
justamente los que tenemos aquí arriba y
ahora multipliquemos del lado derecho
por nuestro vector xy el vector de las
variables y del lado izquierdo vamos a
multiplicar por el vector x pero
transpuesto es decir vamos a ponerlo de
forma horizontal entonces vamos a hacer
este producto muy bien ahora si nosotros
hacemos esto vamos a empezar con la
multiplicación digamos por el lado
derecho es decir vamos a empezar con la
matriz x
el vector muy bien de hecho antes de
continuar si en este momento te sientes
digamos incómodo con el tema de la
multiplicación de matrices quizás
deberías buscar vídeos en khan academy
para aprender o recordar este tema
porque de aquí en adelante voy a suponer
que ya estás familiarizado con este tema
muy bien entonces qué es lo que ocurre
si nosotros hacemos esta primera
multiplicación bueno pues esencialmente
tendremos el primer renglón por este
vector que sería a equis a equis
de porsche ve por
por jay eso sería la primera entrada y
luego tenemos este renglón por este
vector que sería por equis b por equis
sé por qué más se porque entonces esto
nos da un vector de digamos con dos
coordenadas verdad y ahora multiplicamos
por la izquierda por el vector xy que
está digamos acostado verdad está de
forma horizontal entonces este producto
lo podemos hacer muy muy de forma muy
simple verdad simplemente sería esta
primera coordenada por la primera
coordenada del segundo vector y esta
coordenada por la segunda coordenada del
otro vector entonces tendríamos equis
que multiplica a a por equis
por equis más ve por más b
por g
y luego sumamos ya que multiplica a esta
coordenada que en este caso sería b por
x por x + sé porque nace por g
porque muy bien entonces como aquí ya
tenemos puros números entonces podríamos
desarrollar esta expresión verdad
tendríamos a por equis cuadrada
por equis cuadrada aquí tendríamos x por
ver porque entonces sería más b por
equis porque por equis porque y luego
distribuimos este producto y aquí
tendríamos b bueno y por d por equis que
es otra vez de equis y en verdad
entonces en esencia tenemos dos de estos
por eso es que necesitábamos poner el 2
y finalmente tendremos porsche y
entonces aquí tendríamos que agregar más
sé por qué cuadrada más sé por qué
cuadrada entonces si nos damos cuenta
obtuvimos la forma cuadrática con la que
habíamos iniciado verdad con todo y ese
2 entonces ahora lo que nos conviene es
que podríamos expresar todo esto
utilizando una notación un poquito más
abstracta verdad podríamos considerar a
nuestra matriz m verdad vamos a poner
algo así como m mayúscula que representa
a nuestra matriz que por el lado derecho
va a multiplicar a nuestro vector x pero
por el lado izquierdo va a múltiple
cárcel con el vector x transpuesta
verdad que esencialmente representa al
vector pero de forma horizontal verdad y
esta es la forma en la que representamos
de forma vectorial a una forma
cuadrática verdad entonces por ejemplo
si nosotros pensáramos en algo como en
tres dimensiones verdad vamos a hacerlo
más abajo si pensamos en un vector x de
tres dimensiones verdad entonces la
matriz que tenemos aquí debería ser de 3
x 3 y ahora consideramos aquí nuevamente
nuestro vector x verdad entonces nuestra
matriz tendría que ser algo así
ve
verdad vamos a poner aquí de voy a poner
aquí y aquí efe y en realidad lo pongo
de esta forma porque queremos que esta
matriz sea simétrica con respecto a la
diagonal entonces lo que vemos el lado
derecho tendremos que verlo del lado
izquierdo aquí iría un ave acá abajo una
c aquí habría una y muy bien entonces
esta sería nuestra matriz simétrica
verdad luego aquí pondríamos nuestro
vector con tres variables x y y ceta y
del lado izquierdo pondríamos el mismo
vector pero horizontal verdad x y y ceta
y en realidad todo este producto no lo
voy a hacer yo pero si haces todas estas
multiplicaciones de matrices obtendrás
una forma cuadrática con tres variables
y en efecto puede ser quizás una forma
muy complicada verdad pero es es muy
simple de expresar lo verdad simplemente
lo ponemos así y con esta herramienta
digamos a la mano en el próximo vídeo lo
usaremos para escribir la aproximación
cuadrática de las funciones de varias
variables
nos vemos en el próximo vídeo